I support challenges to incumbent
presidents Joe Biden doesn't have any uh
particular claim to the Democratic
nomination just because he's an
incumbent anybody who wants to run
against him should I would like to see
debates I get why the DNC isn't going to
do them because why would you ever
put your uh current president from your
party in a position where they can
really only damage themselves and I
understand why the DNC isn't going to do
debates it's not unique to the
Democratic party it's not unique to Joe
Biden it's not unique to 2024. that
being said the current Challengers to
Joe Biden Bobby Kennedy Jr and Marianne
Williamson are not particularly
impressive to me